and welcome back everybody during the
Idaho College student murders
investigation Moscow police contacted
the makers of the knife believed to be
the murder weapon the probable cause
affidavit says that officers found the
sheath to a k-bar knife next to Madison
mogan's body DNA on that sheath helped
police connect Brian coburger to the
scene the director of sales and
marketing for kabar told TMZ that
investigators contacted the company
about the knives and sheath they sell
but kabar did not have any records of
someone named Brian coburger purchasing
one experts say the knife that would fit
the sheath is a seven inch utility knife
commonly used as a tool by Campers or
Hunters while police haven't found the
knife itself the sheath with coburger's
DNA is on it it's a pretty big get for
the prosecution wouldn't you agree Terry
I think it's a huge get for the
prosecution any time you can get either
the weapon that committed the crime or
something associated with that weapon
you're doing well and here they have
that sheath and according to the
affidavit it was found next to one of
the bodies and it did have DNA on it and
definitely that's going to help convict
co-burger I think it's probably one of
the best pieces of evidence they have at
this time if they of course can find
that knife that's going to really
solidify you know this case but for
right now having the sheath he dropped
it it was a huge mistake on his part
knowing that he is someone who has
specialized has a master's degree
working on his PhD in criminology that
was a huge mistake if in fact he is the
one who dropped that cheek next to the
body
yeah I agree with you Terry the DNA
evidence looks strong in my experience
the DNA evidence tends to always look
strong and arrest affidavits though
prosecutors love using it and judges
love signing off on warrants when they
see it what I would say is let's wait
and see with Coburg arrested and
probable cause made out for the arrest
they also have probable cause they take
a swab of the inside of his cheek for
DNA no if that swab comes now if that
SOB comes back as a match for the
suspect on the sheath it limits your
arguments but doesn't eliminate them
then we start talking about potentially
contaminated crime scenes and how much
of coburger's DNA was on the sheath very
little than maybe the police mishandled
the evidence a lot of DNA maybe touching
things and passing it around that
argument might work but if the DNA test
negative or inconclusive for co-burger
that's where this case gets really crazy
because the defense may have a real case
on their hands so for the DNA I say wait
and see yeah you know what Brian that
sheath isn't the only piece of evidence
that the police have they also have
Footprints and it's based in Blood and
if in fact those Footprints are found to
be Footprints from shoes that coburger
wore I think that sort of seals the case
now look they know for a fact it has a
certain pattern they can look for shoes
with that pattern they've already stated
that it's a diamond pattern close to a
band shoe and if it turns out he has
those shoes in his closet or he's ever
purchased shoes that have that pattern I
think it's going to be just like a
fingerprint and it will definitely seal
the case for the prosecution as far as
that's concerned and we've seen it in
other cases I mentioned this before it
convicted George Wagner the fact that he
had shoes that were very similar to
those shoes that were found at the
footprint in those crime scenes so if
they can do something like that here
they will really I think seal the deal
yeah Terry but that's a big and many
many ifs if they can connect it to
co-burger then that's great but if not
then this whole shoe print it's a
nothing Burger part of the problem is
that this house has a lot of partygoers
and people coming in and out the other
issue is that the authorities are
relying on the testimony of Dylan who
describe how this Mass figure was moving
through the house if the defense can
discredit something as small as the
direction of this person was was moving
in the house her memory of the events
because she was rightfully terrified she
was tired maybe not sober or there is no
link to co-burger and this shoe then
this argument the defense can use to
plant a seed of doubt in the case in the
investigation and argue if they're wrong
here what else are they wrong about the
defense could use this issue to make a
mountain out of a mohill so to speak and
enough of them could cause problems for
the prosecution's case I think we kind
of see a preview of what the trial might
look like when it honestly happens you
know sometime later thanks to both of
you for breaking that down coming up on
Long crime daily children left behind
when a parent dies in an accident caused
by a drunk driver are getting a new kind
of support
and welcome back everybody we close out
Today's Show in Memphis Tennessee where
officials passed a new law to combat
drunk driving and it goes far beyond
prison time the story starts two years
ago in St Louis Missouri an alleged
drunk driver killed Cordell Williams his
fiancee Lacey Newton and their
four-month-old son Cordell Williams II
the suspect 25 year old David Thirlby is
charged with three counts of DUI
resulting in death of another person
court documents reveal that his blood
alcohol level was twice the legal limit
at the time of the crash Williams and
Newton left behind two young children
the name of one of those children is now
on Bentley's law this law was proposed
by his grandmother to force drunk
drivers that kill a parent to provide
financial support to the surviving
children until they turn 18 and graduate
from high school while Bentley's law has
been under consideration in several
States Tennessee is the first and only
state to officially pass it Terry I'll
start with you this new Tennessee law
makes sense but it sounds like it might
be a nightmare to actually administer it
absolutely I think it does make sense
people who are responsible for their
actions do have to pay restitution not
just jail time so I think doing this is
something that all states should be
doing I just think the way they're
talking about administering it is going
to be a logistical nightmare first of
all I think the courts should probably
have a one lump sum at some point
perhaps the defendant should add in some
sort of escrow account monies that would
go towards the family but making sure
that the individual pays is going to be
hard to follow up many of these people
don't have the funds if they're in jail
as the law is stating they have a year
after the fact that they get out of jail
but how are you going to actually
administer that and can you in any way
shape or form if you are in fact the
defendant control what that education is
for those children so I don't think
they're going to be able to logistically
administer it in a fair way I think it's
going to take time to go through the
court systems and I think both parties
are going to be object objecting to the
way it is being administered yeah in
theory Brian it makes sense it sounds
like the right thing to do but if the
children ever going to see the money I
don't think so I mean Terry kind of
touched on it a bit uh it seems to me
like for lack of a better term it's like
trying to get blood from a stone think
about it someone commits a crime let's
say it's a first time offender right
they're in jail for a number of years
because you killed a child's parents
right or parents or parents because both
of them have to be deceased they spend
that much time in jail they have a
felony record who's going to employ them
this is assuming that they're a citizen
of the United States and they don't get
deported to another country because they
get deported whole other issue but if
they're in the country they had another
year how much money are you going to get
out of these people I talk about this as
doing divorces when I was in law school
doing some civil work I know public I'm
a public defender I don't see how they
get it done yeah and it also creates a
continuing relationship with the
children and the person who killed their
parents which is a bit odd in and of
itself Brian Terry thanks so much
everyone thanks for joining us we'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]